it is the idea this is a crazy idea
what's that believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn one
of the most common rules that successful
people follow pursue your crazy ideas
also if you want to know what Eric
Thomas myself Grant Cardone and others
have to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below you've got to make
a sack of fights if you won't get to the
next level you're gonna have to give up
something right if you're doing work
that you love you're more likely to
follow through you're more likely to do
it because it doesn't feel like work
because you love doing it you have to go
build self-confidence
[Music]
I want you to live the life you were
meant to live you hear me
not the life that was given to you I'm a
high school dropout cuz that's the life
my daddy gave me but I've been married
almost 28 years and two kids by the same
woman which is not my experience
I got brothers and sisters none of us
had the same parents because I made up
in my mind that's the life y'all gave me
I'm not that I'm not taking that no more
I don't want I don't want to be on crack
I've never drank I never smoked and I'm
not against it
I just didn't do it because my family
was doing it and they wasn't winning
doing it uncle died of cirrhosis of the
liver I'm like bruh I'm not going out
like that
uncle's in prison I'm not going I wasn't
meant to be in prison I got married at
19 y'all's meant to live with a woman
I'm not I'm not
ain't mad actually brothers being real
it's some dudes they like I'm hardcore
I'm not hard I promise you I'm not hard
I wanna be when the dudes all day every
day
nah I'm gonna need a break I'm gonna
need a break from that I'm just being
real I'm gonna need a break for me and
my man in the same bunk and I ain't got
no privacy I'm gonna need a break from
that I'm just being real I'm gonna need
a break from prison food I'm gonna need
my grandma cooking at some point I'm
just being real just be honest when you
walk out of here some of you are not
transitioning because you're okay with
the life you have and I'm telling you
right when I walk out I want to be an
example of you can start from wherever
and get to wherever you want to get to
that's what I'm asking you to do what
fuse you the reason why you so lazy is
not because you don't have the ability
you so lazy because your dream so small
seven years ago when I started saying we
are going to go to the moon
and we're gonna mind for the resources
and people say that's a freaking crazy
idea and when someone tells you is a
crazy idea that means you're on the
right path because dreams so big that
people think you're absolutely crazy and
when you tell them what you're gonna do
and if they don't think is crazy idea
you're not thinking big enough so think
big and when reason is when someone
tells you it is impossible it be
impossible for them not for you and the
more people who tell you it's impossible
that means more people have taken
themselves out of the solution and now
the field is yours to own yours only
mine and that's just a different way of
looking at it so when I look at as an
entrepreneur I don't focus on what the
world is I focus on what the world can
be so don't look at the glass being half
empty or half full you focus on saying
is this glass what's filling do I want
to fill this glass or not because if I
do that the really matter is half empty
or half full and if I don't do I really
care is half empty or half full right
and that to me is really starting to
think about every time you see something
and you see what is possible what if and
imagine are the two amazing words in the
English dictionary so when I say Louis
imagine what happens to you all the
preconceptions go away and you are
willing to open to anything that I'm
willing to say for at least the next 30
seconds of imagining and then you may
come back and say oh that will never
work but at least you're open for that
time there's a lot of things I want to
do I always wanted to be a director I
think as well I have so many girls come
out to me and tell me that they want to
be models which is fine it's not a bad
thing I just think there's so much to do
I just went to a wonderful talk about
genetic engineering and neuroscience and
this man who is giving the talk
explained it this is like 10,000 kids is
from the age of 7 to 13 who are doing
neuroscience they do these competitions
and one of the things and they're doing
things in your science which haven't
been which weren't done by him until he
was like 30 like how quickly things like
that are changing and but they're not
there is an awareness sport it's cool
stuff like that like that sounds way
cooler to me than being a model but like
no one really knows about it and I just
think there are just so many things I
always say too cause I just dream just
dream bigger go for president just keep
going up astronauts only think big my
mind still running through all the
conversations I had with our
Schwarzenegger last night in his kitchen
talked to him for about an hour's one of
the greatest conversations I've ever had
and that's one of the takeaways think
big you know he told me he said he
always thought big he said don't worry
about failure so much died how far can
you really fall we're all only a few
feet from the ground and I was thinking
mentors you know he told me about his
mentor reg Park his first mentor and I
thought that's what's wrong in the world
that's why it's so easy to feel lost who
do we have guiding our way you know you
got to go out you have to find people
you have to find people who have done it
before who can shorten the path who can
keep you from failure he told me he said
don't fail too much one of the reasons
he doesn't procrastinate and can think
big he said is because he he at 20 years
old won mr. Olympia so he said he got
used to success and he tasted success
and so you know make sure you find some
little wins in life don't always lose
it's a myth that you only want to learn
from mistakes what do you learn from
mistakes they don't have to be yours
though people in the modern world with
all this convenience we have the next
thing you know all you're doing is just
sitting around not accomplishing
anything you know go out conquer the
world conquer your fears
think big that's all I could think you
know he's a big dude strong but his life
was big made some mistakes made a lot of
great attempts and successes it can be
hard to keep perspective when you hit a
rough patch it can be hard to stay sane
and stay motivated and stay optimistic
when you fall on tough times when
something doesn't go right when the
market slows down when you lose a big
customer and that's part of the game of
being an entrepreneur we're gonna have
these highs and lows but hopefully we're
moving forward in the positive direction
and part of winning as an entrepreneur
is just sticking with it it's just
staying on the path it's just every day
getting up and being consistent and
moving forward you only really lose if
you give up right and so you can lose
little battles but if you keep going
you're gonna win the war and I think
what really helps you keep consistent
and keep motivated and keep on every day
getting up and fighting is remembering
the
is remembering your big dream the big
goal what you're trying to accomplish
and so for me I think about untapped
potential you know I think the biggest
problem in the world is untapped human
potential I think if we can solve that
we solve all the major problems of the
world and I think the way to help untap
people or help the unlock them help
bring out that potential is through the
environment right you may not have that
with your friends and your family your
parents the people around you but you
can get that from the books and videos
and the resources that you watching
consume and so it's why I created this
YouTube channel so what keeps me
motivated on a daily basis is thinking
about that big problem the biggest
problem the world is facing is untapped
human potential and if I can create
content that slowly moves people forward
slowly helps unlock a little bit of
potential if you keep hearing the same
message multiple times from different
people slowly it starts to seep in right
the more time you spend around
successful people the more you want to
become successful the more you adopt
their mindset and positivity and the
more you hang around people who are not
accomplishing things who are complaining
and who are negative the more you're
gonna be like those people and so my
solution is to create that for you for
myself I want to be around
uber successful people and have their
mindset seep into me there is no ceiling
for you really there's nothing you can I
don't think there's I mean all are
you're silly there's no ceiling you know
because I mean you've proven that you
can you can cover the whole water front
in terms of kinds of characters yeah
whether it's a boxer or more
quadriplegic or someone it was a
brilliant lawyer the whole range of
stuff mmm you know with the training
that I had that's the way we were
trained you know to play any part
there's no such thing as you can't play
a party Megan I'd be right for a
particular partner but I don't think
there's a part I can't attempt to play I
could at least analyze and try to break
down and put a performance together may
not be any good yeah but I was taught
one of the things that I was taught that
sticks in my mind was a gentleman by the
name of Bill ball who was the artistic
director of America
Conservatory Theater in San Francisco
and he always talked about failing big
so if you're gonna fail fail big and I'm
like I like that for I do too I did you
know I'm not a fallback mentality kind
of person people would say well you know
you better have another career to fall
back on I'm like I don't want to fall
back on anything if I fall I'm gonna
fall forward I want to see what I'm
hitting or find exactly you know what I
mean I don't wanna burn I never
understood that mentality neither I
never understood it I'm like I'm going
that way I'm yeah I mean if you worry
about being safe and secure and if it's
security
well if security is your by word then
you know you're gonna you're never gonna
reach out and do anything I don't think
that's gonna protect you that's right
you know I was gonna give you any kind
of genuine satisfaction you know if you
could feel worried about that then you
know it was a lie in other words if
you're a sailor you would never leave
port the right I only care about
security there was an IQ the question I
think was an IQ question or they had
nine dots yeah and you had to connect
the dots I think with five the lines
without lifting the pencil the only way
you could do it was to go outside the
box yeah you know when people sit there
with it to go out man that's right you
can't do it what you can't nobody said
you can't go outside the box yeah you
know I grew up in Lake Charles Louisiana
for those of you done than my story and
my dad my dad was he had five kids wife
he was dedicated and committed to being
the provider for his family like many of
you are how many of you provide for your
family probably want to do a good job at
my dad wanted to do a good job at it so
my dad died when I was ten years old he
had he had owned a life insurance
company he actually started a life
insurance company it was taken from him
and a partner and was taken from him at
the age of I guess he was 42 years old
42 years old he's got five kids he's got
a wife to take care of a no job how many
been in transition before yeah
so 42 lotta obligation now start to move
into the middle class 42 years old he's
got a he's got twin boys coming they
didn't plan us you know good Catholic
family
doing the planning every five years we'd
have a baby so he was plant you could
tell like like when I look back in my in
his life today there's a long answer to
a short question but like like you guys
you guys need to figure out your your
your why you're going to do whatever
you're gonna do my dad knew why he was
gonna do what he was going to do but my
dad didn't think big enough it's it's
it's it's a it's a I got two things for
my dad one every day he worked he was up
early
he stayed late he's in transition
between 42 and 50 - he's in transition
in his life
right he's having to go from life
insurance company big dream company gets
stolen away from him he's like what am i
doing right this is a story the middle
class right here this is called gravity
this is yesterday's Miami bridge falling
and everybody's like okay believe that
happened
structures fall folks so this is what I
learned from my dad my mom had to sell a
dream house that was paid for in cash my
dad bought a dream house a year and a
half before he bought up before he died
we all went in celebrated oh my god this
is unbelievable this is crazy this is
great we made it to the middle class my
dad dies my mom has to sell the house a
week literally a week after my dad dies
when she should have been grieving she
was having to sell this dream house you
understand what I'm saying this is what
I learned when I was 2 years old man
life is short okay my dad didn't provide
he did he worked hard but he didn't have
enough because if he had enough my mom
would not have had to sell the dream
house everybody agree with that okay
my mom did not know how to produce new
income so my mom had to go into
conservation so when you asked me the
question how did you start I started
with the wrong data okay I started with
the wrong data and the data was hey life
is short something Bad's gonna happen
all that's true but if you could out
produce if you could produce enough
income you could start solving some of
these problems like indestructible
income you send unfinished work
- Stephen Sondheim for him to critique
Steve just tell me what you think how
does that work and are you really really
it's Immelt ins a crazy idea it's a
crazy idea but in my head it was a
really good idea and sometimes what you
need are people to just not say as a
terabyte and to be very careful about
who you let in when you had a good idea
because people get crush it for you even
though I stick to this other thing and
you trust that person and you love that
person it can really affect your own
view of your work I've learned that the
hard way I've had ideas die in front of
me because people I respect to go maybe
not thought about so much by when I was
on vacation and I picked up Charles book
and I started reading it reading it to
my wife and being like there's something
here right this is like I'm not a crazy
person
no that's a really cool idea like that's
as responsible for this as anything and
I remember when I first met sometime it
was to do translations for the last
revival of recite story and we talk we
talk shop when we talk about whether it
should translate what I shouldn't and we
kind of talked about that for about a
half an hour then he asked me like what
are you thinking about next because
Heights was running at the time was its
first year and I said I think I had this
idea Alexander Hamilton and he threw up
his head and made this and she's a
really reserved guy and he went the most
incredible idea
just instantly God
and that's also is responsible for us
being here is anything that early
encouragement not just you know his
whole thing and he's proved it with his
career is continued to vary and like you
needed to what scares you and lean into
what people don't think makes a good
musical and make that goals continue to
change and continue to get bigger and I
think as I as I sort of reached certain
milestones certain accomplishments you
know it only makes me realize that I
need to dream bigger and I think that
same thing for you guys I think as you
really build that confidence through
your career as you really start start
you know building your career and
building your relationships and seeing
your dreams actually realized you just
have to continue to keep dreaming bigger
and that's why it's so important to
always continue learning in my opinion
because there's always there's there
you've never made it I think we all can
always continue to do let's do more to
be better and bigger
for example when I started LinkedIn and
I went to all Mike because you should go
to all your smart friends and ask them
when I went to all my smart friends had
asked them they basically two-thirds of
them said I was eighty an idiot for
starting LinkedIn it was like there's a
crazy idea that some that's a good
signal right and the reason it's a good
signal is because of a hundred percent
of people think it's good there's almost
always problems that you're not seeing
and that unless other people think it's
good too that the competition pile
around it is serious so I like the fact
that you say why would smart people
think this is not a good idea but
actually in fact there's something that
makes it a good idea even despite that
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with bishop TD jakes on how to go big
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move who just watch another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
answer these questions in the comments
below here we go question number one
what is your crazy idea number two how
can you dream bigger and number three
what is one step you could take today to
move closer to your dream happening
always go to something bigger than
yourself
I'm wondering if you've been defeated
because you have been giving yourself
wholly to something that was too small
to hold you have you thrusts yourself
into a glass of water if have you leapt
off the diving board into a cereal bowl
person are you not guilty of immersing
yourself into things that were too small
to hold your vision oh my god they're so
good I'm gonna get the CD myself Jesus
sent him to throw himself into something
that was bigger than his condition and
he had to go to get to it he had to get
out of his comfort zone
my problem is so many times you've
thrown big ideas as small people
you've given big commitment to cereal
--bowl people and you're trying to get
your sight back from a source that's too
small to support what you're willing to
put in is your investment bigger than
the bank you should see the way you're
looking at me is you're it's the reason
you keep being disappointed by people is
that you have wholly throwing yourself
into something that was too small Jesus
sends him to something that is bigger
than himself so he can wash his eye are
you trying to take a bath in a bowl the
most important work ever if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple so it
would be like a little beacon if you
want to learn how to stop wasting your
life away check out the video right next
to me I think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there 99.9%
of the people that watch or listen to
this content are living in the middle
the fact that you're full of false